A FEW HOURS OF MARCH FIFTIES
HERE MICHAEL PLEASE GIVE VICE
AUDIO RECORDING FOR SEASON THE
MAIN SCREEN TELEVISED MATTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
FLORA GRAYSON THERE KAMLAGER
HERE MAIENSCHEIN HERE MATHIS
HERE QUIRK SILVA HERE FOR
ALMOST RIVAS JR WICKS. FOUR WE
HAVE A QUORUM HEALTH DISSENSION
SO MODE MOVE ON MR MATHIS
SECONDED BY MS WICKS- ANSWER TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AWAY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
FLORA- FOR AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE AYE QUIRK
SILVA OKAY QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS
SITE RAMOS I RIVAS. RIVAS IRON
WORKS FIVE I QUESTIONS MOTIONS
PASSED THAT WHICH WAS RELEASED.